Geraldo Rivera channels his good friend  Donald Trump on Dancing with the Stars  mark my words we're gonna make dance  great again  after getting off to a rough start last  week Geraldo turned the beat around and  went with this approach instead  Vladimir hi it's Donald that was huge it  was huge hey black did you hold on for a  second Melania the 72 year old TV  personality put his own twist on a trump  afid salsa a performance that earned him  compliments but again the night's lowest  score 13 well unfortunately you did not  make dance great again but you did make  me laugh plenty of bravado but I tell  you impressive for all the wrong reasons  faraldo's drumstick apparently wasn't  enough he and partner adidas Lewinsky  were the first couple to be eliminated  he opened up to ET after the show first  of all it's dancing so you can't really  get too upset about it I'm just not much  of a dancer unless I'm tequila drunk at  my wedding and then you can test that I  was really berries